[Music]
is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 percent discount on
a wide range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
assalamu alaikum
i recently saw a clip a very short clip
of joe rogan saying good words about
islam
this is change of heart there's a change
of mind
let's take a look at what he has to say
come back and comment
islam originally was the they were
scientists man
i mean they were they if you look at
these the early islamic world they were
the ones that
were the most advanced at one point in
history they were the ones that were
pushing mathematics and science and
and reason and logic you know it's just
it
it comes in cycles man it comes in
cycles of suppression and dominance and
you know the the real concern is
unstoppable dictatorships like china and
russia and
when when there's no dissent and no
discussion
i've got a lot of friends who are arabs
i spend a lot of time in the middle east
i love them they're awesome there are
some factions that
say we've got to go blow ourselves up
and that's obviously some factions of
christianity
too right 100
absolutely in america right and i
guarantee you absolutely we were being
invaded and attacked
by muslims all the time it'd probably be
some radical fundamentalist christians
that would want to do the same thing
right that some some muslim sex have
done so first thing i want to say is
that this is
much more of a positive and constructive
tone
than what we have been used to with the
joe rogan experience
in the last half decade or so and
obviously there's something welcome that
you speak in this manner and start
looking in a positive
way about the religion of islam and it's
high time that that is the case and you
say a few good words about the religion
of islam
but i want to remind you of something
that malcolm x
uh beautifully verbalized and he said
you stick a knife
in my back nine inches and pull out
and pull it out six inches there's no
progress
if you pull it out all the way and
that's not progress
progress is healing the wound that the
blow made
and they haven't even pulled out the
knife out
much less heal the wound they won't even
admit the knife is there
to be honest with you this i have to
just admit my disappointment with
much of what you guys do and when i see
you guys
kind of so-called alt-right
uh commentators on internet that you've
got your knife in the back of the muslim
community's back
and you're maybe slowly pulling it out
but you don't even want to admit it's
there
talking about us talking at
us and not to us scarcely
seldomly to us
and i say this that has to change
if discourse is going to be positive in
the next half decade
what i wanted to say in the remainder of
this video
was i wanted to give you our perspective
as muslims
on the purpose of life because one of
the things you said
was when we're talking about the kaab
and the circumambulation
of muslims around the black box which is
called the kaaba
which is of course one of the the
pillars of islam hajj pilgrimage you
said it does something for them
let's hear what you said and come back
and comment on this you know when you
watch
the muslims uh gather around mecca and
go around the circle
you don't think there's something kind
of beautiful about that amazing about
that they all
peacefully get there they're all dressed
the same and they all like move around
this thing and show respect
obviously it's doing something for them
it has this profound
effect on them joe rogan i want to be
honest with you because i know you're
watching this video i know for a fact
you're watching this video in fact
yeah i want to be honest with you and
tell you that this
language that you're using um it's doing
something for them
it's revelatory of your own
bias and i think your bias may be
something which is referred to in ethics
as egoism
or even in psychology as egoism this
idea
that things should be done for us like
we are the center of attention
that we should be acting on our
self-interest and really that is the
basis for morality not only that
but the purpose of life therefore is for
us to try and get as much of it as we
can
let it do something for us like a slave
life is a slave to us and we're just
here
telling life what to do and this comes
quite
frequently in your podcast if i may be
honest with you and tell you
whether it's you telling people or
asking them about lsds
telling them about your experiences
smoking a big cigar and doing this and
that's what
or you know hgh that you take and the
palumbo ism that you have or the
chain facial change that you've seen
because of the steroid abuse and so on
this is just you are a caricature
and i don't mean this to be rude you are
a caricature of materialism
you basically are emblematic and this is
not the purpose of life we want to say
that the purpose of
life is not so that we may consume
things and it can do things for us
before we
hit the grave the purpose of life is to
worship our creator
that's the purpose of life that we have
a creator he created the human beings
which we we can reason rationally
the purpose of life is to worship that
creator
that's the purpose of life to submit
ourselves to that creator
rousseau very famously said man is born
free but everywhere in chains
the quran states allah
[Music]
has put forward a parable of two men
one of them has many slave masters
and the other one has only one slave
master
are they the same praise be to god
that most people don't understand
meaning
meaning you will always be a slave to
something or someone
whether it's your own desires or
societal expectations
or materialism or a combination of all
those things
or you can decide to be the slave or
submission in submission to the one who
created you and the
quranic message is very straightforward
joe rogan
it's that you have to make the right
decision the purpose of life is to
worship god not to worship yourself
not to worship societal expectations and
you will not receive
happiness tranquility and purpose in
life
you'll be stuck in the second gear of a
meaningless lifestyle
if you think that you can fill the void
of purpose with all of the activities
that you are partaking in
they have no ability in fact
or facility to fill that void is
impossible
the only way to fill that void is
through god the creator
the creator god which is sustaining the
universe and maintaining us
so it's not for us to be expecting from
god or what can religion do for us
it's the wrong question the right
question is what's the purpose of life
and what can we do to meet that purpose
we say the purpose of life is to worship
god
it's really as straightforward and
simple as that submit our will to god
and the world is like a shadow joe rogan
the world is like a shadow all the
happiness they're in
is like a shadow the more you try
and walk towards it the more
it moves away from you
and that's what you'll find i'm sure you
have already found that joe rogan
and what you will continue to find the
pursuit of happiness therefore
which is a phrase that's entrenched
in the american documents is nothing but
a mirage
is nothing but a delusion
and the true way out of nihilism
and a completely purposeless lifestyle
is a strong purpose which can only be
granted
through the creator god we're happy to
have these conversations joe rogan
and we need to have this conversation so
you need to think deeply about what i've
said
because you don't have much time to be
to be honest with you on this planet
how long how old are you i mean would
you respect
you're pushing 60 now are you you know
how old are you
how are joe rogan and it's not even
about age because people die
in their uh when they're young but
you're pushing 60 now jorgen
10 20 more years you you know it's over
really you can't even
you know if you take hdh from the horse
himself it's not going to be
putting you back into the age of youth
so you need to start thinking about the
purpose of life
and think about the grave as heidiger
said
as his preferable advice that if you
want authenticity in life
think about the grave
go to quran the abstracts versus
pages and time spent reading and the
verses to pages function
takes you from reading a few verses a
day to a few
pages a day this project is for the real
enthusiasts
if there's enough of us out there this
will become the future of quran
apps and support the project if you can
inshaallah may allah bless all of you
jazakallahu
you